apple's iphone event is happening one
week from today and we just got some
bombshell leaks in terms of what we
should expect alongside the brand new
iphone 14 lineup with some new leaks
that are confirming some of the things
that we were not sure about and boy this
stuff gets crazy because there are some
new features that were not confirmed
before but we know we are getting them
now so i am so excited for this apple
event now let's get into those new
details so we just got a new massive
iphone 14 leak dump from a source called
ux1122 on naver which seems like a
korean source which in the past he has
said some things that were actually
correct so there is some merit to these
leaks now first of all he says that the
storage is gonna start at 128 gigs once
again now we thought that it could be
256 at one point based on another leak
but it looks like it's gonna be 128
again and that actually matches up to
what mark grumman told me during the
interview that we had recently on top of
that we're getting faster 30 watt wired
charging we are getting the a16 ship
that has better thermals now i'm not
sure if this is due to the actual a16
chip because the a16 chip is rumored to
be based on the same n5p architecture as
the a15 so you wouldn't really expect it
to be much more cool however we did get
some leaks from ming chaquel previously
that apple was working on a new thermal
system with vapor chamber cooling and
maybe that's why it's going to be cooler
so i am super excited for that on top of
that we are going to be getting stronger
mag safe magnets yes if you have the
iphone 12 or 13 lineup and you're kind
of annoyed because the magnet's not
strong enough on the back of the iphone
well they're gonna be stronger this year
and i'm super excited for that and on
top of that we're getting a new mac safe
battery accessory now we already have
the apple max a battery pack which a lot
of people do not like because it doesn't
work that well and it's pretty slow so
hopefully apple releases a much better
one and i really hope apple puts max
safe magnets on the back of the actual
battery pack itself we are expecting
better battery life and he did say that
prices may be in a completely different
direction than expected now i don't
really know what that means but he did
translate it to it saying it will be
more expensive and the price gap between
models may change too now in my personal
opinion i think that the iphone 14
regular model will stay at the same 799
with the new 14 max at 8.99 and then
both the pro and pro max models are
gonna be a hundred dollars more
expensive than they currently are now so
eleven hundred dollars for the pro and
1200 for the pro max now moving on we
just got a huge leak concerning the
ultra wide camera on the iphone 14 pro
models this year saying that it's gonna
have bigger pixels than before which
means low light performance will be
improved now actually going to the leak
itself it's from minshakuo who is very
reliable and as for the specifics going
to mingxiquo's actual tweet he says that
the iphone 14 pro models ultrawide
cameras will upgrade to 1.5 micron size
pixels versus 1.0 on the current iphone
13 pro now if you don't know how the
pixel sizes are measured it's actually
just one side of the pixel so if it's
one micron long it's also one micron
wide so it's one square micron now going
up to 1.4
is actually going to be squared which is
1.9
square microns versus one square micron
on the current 13 pro that's basically
double the surface area of each pixel
which means almost double the amount of
light going into each pixel if you keep
the same 12 megapixel sensor size that's
going to be a huge low light improvement
now moving on it looks like we did get a
leak of the actual sticker of an iphone
14 pro model so yes that name is for
sure confirmed and that it's coming in a
white box at least the pro devices on
top of that we also have confirmation
that all iphone 14 models are going to
feature six gigabytes of ram of course
with the pro models having the faster
ram and going even further we have
confirmation that there will no longer
be a sierra blue color and there will
not be a titanium model we're going to
be keeping the stainless steel for the
pros again and interestingly dan roo did
come out and talk about the 30 watt
charger that's going to be coming out
for the iphone 14 series however he did
say that the peak power of the lightning
interface of the iphone is only 27 watts
that's the maximum and the newer higher
setting to enable 30 watt is not going
to be available so i think apple is
going to be future proofing this 30 watt
charger for next year's iphone 15 series
and beyond that will be able to accept
30 watts through the usb c port now this
right here is absolutely crazy it's
rumored that apple and global star will
be announcing satellite connectivity for
the iphone 14 lineup at the september
7th event now this is nuts but it makes
total sense because in february
globalstar announced that it acquired 17
new satellites to provide continuous
satellite services to a potential
customer which might be apple and i
think that makes total sense in terms of
this rumor because you're going to be
able to go out hiking out in the ocean
on your boat yacht whatever any place
where there's no service and you will be
able to get some satellite connectivity
just enough to make a text message or a
voice call hopefully because right now
you have to buy a satellite phone with a
subscription service and apple is just
going to kill that market now moving on
mainstream quote did say that apple has
completed hardware tests for iphone 14
satellite connectivity so they're ready
but the launch is going to depend on the
partners and if they are ready on time
so i think we're really getting this
feature now let's move on to the apple
watch series 8 lineup and we just got
some new leaks from shrimp apple pro
about what we should expect now as far
as a regular series 8 we should expect
the same 41 and 45 millimeter sizing
options no differences there we are
going to be getting an updated red color
the same packaging and contents and
plentiful supply at launch so don't
expect any supply issues or demand
issues at all shrimp apple pro did say
that the box design with the seal is
going to be staying the same except that
they added more glue underneath to make
sure that it shows that you actually
opened it and people can't kind of fake
it and re-box it or anything like that
and as far as the series 8 pro he did
say that that is coming alongside a new
se watch with no major changes for the
se but the 8 pro will have some changes
and it's going to be a surprise to
people because it's going to be a one
more thing type of announcement however
there is a caveat and a potential issue
because there are rumors saying that the
pro apple watch is not going to be
compatible with older watch bands which
means that if you made a collection of
watch bands over the years you might
have to restart all over again but don't
worry because mark german did tweet
about it saying that he believes the
apple watch pro will support older bands
though maybe they won't fit as well or
look as seamless given the size of the
new watch so basically it's technically
going to fit but it's not going to look
great so you're probably just going to
buy a pro apple watch band anyway and on
top of that we also got a leak from the
japanese website mac atakara saying that
the apple watch pro is going to be
featuring a larger 47 millimeter case
size with a flat display yes it's going
to be flat which is going to allow it to
have thinner bezels and basically a
larger display within a smaller chassis
so it doesn't look massive on your wrist
and i totally agree with that i think
it's going to look absolutely amazing
and now putting the iphone and the apple
watch aside we did get a leak from
trimmed apple pro about the air pods pro
2 and the actual feature that might be
coming with it which is going to be huge
and this might be coming at the
september 7th event i'm not exactly sure
let's hope for it but shrimp a pro did
say that the lc3 codec that was leaked
is actually not for lossless but for
normal data transmission like calling
and stuff
with lossless actually having a
completely new codec which is likely a
custom apple codec that they built for
loss lossless support on the airpods pro
2 so i think that is going to be a major
selling point for those new airpods pro
2. a lot of people are going to buy it
because the quality is going to be
absolutely insane and industry changing
and finally we got some details about
apple's ar vr headset that is going to
be launching probably within the next
year who knows maybe there's a chance
apple might give us a teaser at the
september 7th event but apple applied
for trademarks of reality one reality
pro and reality processor and felipe is
thinking that reality processor means
the new family of chips just like the a
series and the m series for the max the
r series is going to be for the arvr
headsets with reality one being the r1
chip and reality pro being the name of
the device which likely means that this
is going to be very expensive and not
meant for the consumer market so
hopefully we get a teaser of that at the
apple september event now let me know
what you're excited for down in the
comments section below because i am
extremely excited definitely subscribe
by clicking the circle above and check
out one of those two right there and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]